bonjour Booba est un habitué des Clash
mais il s'est aussi faire des
compliments voilà plusieurs jours qu'il
ne tarit pas d'éloges sur Aya Nakamura
le rappeur à vous avoir été sceptique au
début de la carrière de la chanteuse
mais son dernier album La convaincu
c'est la bosse
encore et que
[Rires]
ça c'est jamais arrivé c'est incroyable
je suis pas sûr qu'on est entendu à
l'antenne mais sur le plateau on l'a
clairement entendu et tout le monde a
entendu et Booba rêve d'une
collaboration avec elle on parle le
futuring qu'il a imaginé et publié sur
les réseaux
ah ouais mdr a réagi Aya Nakamura
laconique
je prends l'exemple moi de Chaplin qu'on
considère comme un génie qui a un mec
qui refait 200 fois la même prise donc
il a passé la plupart de sa carrière
professionnelle a raté des trucs mais
c'est juste parce que il cherchait la
chose qui voulait
des idées aussi non non c'est un mec qui
a passé du temps qui a passé énormément
de temps c'est donc c'est tout sauf un
génie l'image qu'on a du génie c'est le
mec qui arrive carrément pour de vrai je
pars demain à l'étranger pour finir mon
film
aucun racisme mais ils sont moches tes
mexicains
mais c'est pas c'est pas malin d'être un
tascheron d'être un laborieux c'est bien
d'être un laborieux alors Aurélie la
ceinture en paille j'aime pas du tout
les appareils c'est pour les chapeaux ou
dans la ferme sinon ça se met pas ok la
robe j'aime pas les coeurs mais là on
dirait que vous avez une dent contre
Aurélie au secours pour la meuf comment
elle s'habiller elle est là elle a mis
une robe on dirait une nappe elle a mis
un truc en dentelle on dirait un pyjama
une grosse ceinture enfin il y a rien
qui va au secours bienvenue chez nous ah
ben regarde mon Bruno il y a une petite
phrase pour toi plus tu es lourd plus tu
es difficile à kidnapper protège-toi
mange du gâteau moi
je suis protégé on est dans la même
catégorie tous les deux je voudrais
remercier le bleu parce que le bleu
c'est le bleu c'est très important merci
le bleu on applaudit au bleu
le bleu le bleu bleu bleu bleu
mais par contre si je parle de toi tu as
vu la tête que tu as vu le costard que
tu as ça se fait plus c'est quel bleu
bleu
et ouais moi je suis très critique très
cash pistache je dis ce que je pense de
toute façon cette semaine moi je suis là
pour gagner pour avoir que la victoire
je suis pas là pour gratter l'amitié
très clairement un tonnerre
d'applaudissement pour le fuchsia
le verre
et vous ne voulez pas le garder je veux
pas le garder non parce que c'est pas
mon trip quoi je veux dire il rentre pas
dans mon intérieur c'est pas le style à
la maison
que vous n'utiliseriez pas non mais
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas alors elle a
une spécialiste du puzzer on le sait ça
fait 8 ans que nos besoins ensemble
[Applaudissements]
ils ont 18 enfants là ça devient un
petit quelque chose eux savent ce qui
est une famille une seule femme il y a
un seul utérus
vous seriez très surpris 18 enfants
ah non moi un seul peut vous le détruire
oui vous avez des femmes pendant 8 et
qui ont un périnée Casse-Noisette ça n'a
rien à voir un animal d'abord
attirer l'attention de la femelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle n'a pas l'air très impressionné on
va applaudir le blanc même si le blanc
n'a pas toujours été clean dans
l'histoire
lui il sait ce que c'est une famille
nombreuse regardez il a 102 enfants on
vient de la prendre et c'est le record
du monde mais il y a plusieurs mères
alors là mon avis il voyage gratuitement
à la SNCF l'AFP vient de rencontrer ce
monsieur qui est père donc de 102
enfants allant de 10 à 50 ans record du
monde et effectivement alors il y a eu
12 femmes aujourd'hui il a 68 ans et à
l'AFP vient de déclarer ça y est je
m'arrête là je fais plus d'autres
enfants j'ai du mal à retenir les noms
ça c'est quand même
phoque lui réserve une surprise et
déroule le grand jeu
[Musique]
elle semble intriguée
moi j'ai une petite question du coup
c'est de la viande du poisson
c'est de la viande ou c'est du poisson
pendant que les Saint-Jacques c'est quoi
ton avis c'est de la viande du poisson
du coup et ça Jacques oui mais c'est de
la viande ou du poisson enfin c'est pas
compliqué comment la Saint-Jacques déjà
je comprends pas pourquoi c'est un
prénom Jacques c'est pour un humain pas
pour incrusté
dans l'espace parce que l'air la
nourriture et les liquides qui se
trouvent dans l'estomac flottent
ensemble comme des bulles plein de
morceaux donc si on essaye de roter tout
remonte pas seulement l'air donc du coup
pour BO Norbert on pète davantage un
Japonais lèche une bouteille de sauce
soja et la repose sur la table du
restaurant quelques secondes plus tard
le même réitère son geste avec un verre
ces blagues de mauvais goût dégoûtent et
indignes dans ce pays réputé autant pour
sa politesse que pour sa propreté car le
phénomène est de plus en plus répandu
sur les réseaux sociaux sous le nom de
sushis terrorisme il y a cinq questions
à la fin des cinq questions le meilleur
d'entre vous viendra des fils Norbert à
tes souhaits bienvenue à tous dans ce
cluster
c'est l'endroit idéal pour passer
l'hiver à l'abri du monde extérieur
ici ils ont tout le temps de se
reproduire
[Musique]